as companies start to collect large
amounts of data from an ever-increasing
number of locations building a data
pipeline can be quite the challenge join
us as we talk to two sigma about how
they architected a data pipeline to fit
their many demands on this episode of
stack chat thanks for joining us tell us
a little bit more about two sigma and
why your data pipeline was so complex to
build sure so two Sigma we make use of
data science and technology to uncover
value essentially we can buy massive
amounts of data along with computing
power and financial expertise to develop
sophisticated trading models we need to
ingest and process data and
ever-increasing rate laws protecting it
from exfiltration either accidental or
malicious so can you show us how you
were able to keep up with the demands of
so much data sure let's take a look at
diagram our first attempt at this was to
have a GCP project which was connected
to the Internet this allowed us to
arrange for vendor data to be ingested
from various sources such as s3 or FTP
this enabled us to have an environment
where our researchers were able to
explore datasets and discover new
features from there our engineers could
build data pipelines using native
services like bigquery Google Cloud
storage and data protocol data flow this
enabled us to rapidly derive insights
from the data and on in a more scalable
manner when the compared to our on
premise environment you mentioned
earlier that you needed to protect the
data can you tell us more about how you
dealt with that in this environment as
you can imagine the security of our
intellectual property both internal and
external is of paramount importance as a
result any operations that deal with the
movement of data in or out of the
company's network must be as secure as
possible so the most significant concern
with this design was the fact that the
project was created to the Internet
although this made it easy to ingest
data it also forced us to isolate our
engineers within the environment we
essentially allow them to use native
services but only from instances within
the project essentially creating a DMZ
like setup this was a pain because it
required us to maintain two separate iam
identities one with full privileges and
one with heavy restrictions that could
be used safely on site
you mentioned handling the import of
data from lots of locations how did you
accomplish this and did you see any
impact from dealing with the size of
this data so dealing with multiple
sources was relatively easy in some
cases we had automated jobs which would
collect data from sources such as FTP
in many other cases we were able to
leverage the storage transfer service
for interacting with vendors who would
share their data by rs3 this was great
as it removed the need for us to build
anything bespoke for the job going back
to security how did you ensure that only
the right people can access your data
the key change we made is that the
product is now part of a secure
perimeter this is a concept from the
secure VPC product essentially it allows
us to have fine-grained control over who
has access to data stored within
bigquery and GCS the other key
difference is that we use private
interconnect between two Sigma and
Google with that in place we could
enable engineers and researchers to
safely access the data using native
tools directly from within to Sigma
without the risk it can be shared
outside the other bonus would prime
interconnect was that we had dedicated
bandwidth for data transfers ultimately
the new architecture was a game-changer
for our data engineering team they can
now operate independently without
impacting anyone else within the company
now this has been running well for a
while and you've learned a lot along the
way if you could go back and do it again
what would you do differently well one
thing we've rather glossed over so far
is the way in which we ingest data in
the new environment the secure via PC
product makes it very easy to look down
where our data can be accessed from but
it also introduces a new level of
complexity when dealing with getting
data from external sources this also
required us to think carefully about how
secure API traffic is routed between to
Sigma and these projects in order to do
this we implemented a security PC
concept called bridging this allowed us
to use a single product as the Gateway
for all other secure traffic which is
ease management but presents us with a
new bottleneck which we have concerns
with in the long run in terms of
scalability this is something we'll look
to address as we onboard more teams
so by architecting carefully we were
able to handle large volumes of
unpredictable external data combine
those with our internal datasets and
stay secure thanks so much for giving us
some insight into how you built your
data pipeline to handle all of these
challenges a pleasure if you'd like to
get some hands-on experience and try
setting up a V PC perimeter for yourself
check out the quick guide in the
description
thanks for watching and make sure to
subscribe to the Google cloud platform
channel for more great content we'll see
you next time on snack chat
[Music]
you